pop
poru de belem le cours normales
d'enseignement ménager de paris a choisi
la puériculture comme thème de son
exposition 1957
voici les travaux de ces jeunes filles
futurs professeurs d'enseignement
ménager pendant deux ans elles ont réuni
et fort bien présentes et vous pouvez le
voir toute la documentation sur la
première enfance recherches minutieuses
variées elles les aideront à devenir de
bons professeurs de puériculture des
élèves des cours d'enseignement ménager
en voici elles sont soixante quinze
mille de 11 à 17 ans dans les écoles
communales à paris et dans la cei
[Musique]
la croissance l'alimentation l'hygiène
de bébé pour elles n'auront plus de
secrets et quand les jeunes filles
apprennent la puériculture les enfants
se portent mieux
la mortalité diminue chez les tout
petits
[Musique]
dans les cours d'enseignement ménager en
fait aussi la cuisine du repassage du
raccommodage de la couture et de
l'économie domestique bien sûr
[Musique]
et
mary culture et géographie au sénégal
bébé et beauté attaché à sa mère par une
bande de toiles caché par les chats
mademoiselle mathieu inspectrice
générale chez les indiens sioux le petit
nuage rouge est glissée dans un étui un
étui en pot
[Musique]
au pays des eskimos flocons de neige est
blotti dans le capuchon de l'anorak mais
la nuit il dort tout nu dans les bras de
sa mère le bébé de la belle hindoue a
pour tout costume une chaîne d'or autour
de la taille et du col autour des yeux
contre les microbes rétrospective ivème
siècle avant jésus-christ gracieux
évocation du bas relief de la proa de
cette beauté grecs à deux jumeaux
emmailloté les mains le long du corps
[Musique]
elle a aussi une jeune nourrice
15e siècle aucassin est entouré de
bandelettes et catherine sa nourrice a
été choisie parce qu'elle a l'oeil clair
le visage agréable capote et crinoline
le second empire sied bien à la féminité
élégance aussi pour la robe de bébés
fine lingerie et dentelle
[Musique]
autre temps autre méthode
mais partout et toujours les mêmes
gestes tendres les petits gestes
protecteur de l'amour maternel
[Musique]